the Joe Rogan experience yeah but I
think everybody that has these I don't
want to hear that I want to shut down
speech I don't like things right but
there are some people that are really
consistent but I like to think I am but
only social media companies have the
power to decide whether or not gets to
express whether or not a person gets to
express themselves to an unlimited
amount of people it's an understand if
you tell them that based on your
ideology which most people don't agree
with it's on your ideology they have
said enough that something that merits
you taking away their ability to express
themselves then I think you open up a
real discussion much like the Second
Amendment discussion among the First
Amendment that what are we doing here
what is this and what is free speech and
is this a town hall and Jack Dorsey from
Twitter believes it's a town hall he
thinks everyone should have the ability
to express themselves but that like
everything well it's [ __ ] complicated
a mess it certainly is nadine strossen
who i think used to be something at the
ECL you wrote a book about speech and
about how in Germany you're not allowed
to fly the swastika and they have
censorship on speech and that it's not
effective for any of the outcomes that
it's intended for they also make a lot
of [ __ ] porn is that right German the
Germans could use anyone the plugger
I don't think I know any names but for
whatever reason a lot of [ __ ] the thing
[ __ ] porn it's not a thing I I try to be
very open-minded but I don't I don't
understand I'm not gonna don't have to
understand it you know I don't some
people you allow people to do it right I
would never allow people to think about
of course yeah that's a weird one right
a weird it's yeah people want [ __ ] in
people's mouths and oh and smother
themselves and [ __ ] at each other my
instant reaction is what went on what's
that about oh hey where's that I want to
I want that story yeah I want that
script how do you get to to that that
sounds very abusive and it sounds sure
like it's it's a tough thing thought but
no but no the idea of censoring speech
it backfires it's just not healthy but I
think people should be generally
sensitive and not [ __ ] at the same
time and it's also the thing about
someone saying something in print that
you read on Twitter it's like you can't
even say anything back to them you make
your own comment but you're like [ __ ]
this is such a shitty way to talk it's
poison yeah it's a shitty way okay yeah
I don't engage in it
I'll post things up that I think are
interesting how did you evolve on it
just decided it's not these arguments or
not they make you riled up they're not
healthy they're not they don't they're
not I told my daughter hold on I'm
arguing with someone on Twitter said it
out loud and I was like oh I'm the
shittiest that's the shittiest thing
that I could be doing just right now so
it was unmanageable when you get to a
certain number of hours I just can't
because there's no way you can and it's
also people just like they're [ __ ] in
their cubicle they're just trying to get
a rise other people they're angry
they're [ __ ]
they're bored you can't expect that
everybody's existing in the same
vibration that you have to a tweeted
said you're a pitiful person I was like
I don't know good morning bro you're not
no no I'm doesn't even know yeah it
doesn't faze me at all but it shouldn't
if it doesn't it's it is fascinating
that someone would write such a thing it
is but it's not click on him and be like
I wonder what his deal is clearly he's
projecting and I'm worried about
I wonder what happen in that guy you
look at their way you look at their
picture and then you decide everything
about their life did you ever look like
there's nothing reason I can't run for
Congress I think like I want to keep
doing stand-up and I want to talk about
things like you ever look at a guy like
the guy I run in the car from yesterday
at LAX I thought about how much he jerks
off for a little while and never think
about that I I will sometimes like I bet
that guy isn't good for him and whatever
but that kind of I know I brought that
up I'll think about that now I really
shine in the mouth but the I watch the
video once this lady now this driver was
really in she's gonna do it guys
[ __ ] in her mouth and she would she
was speaking in German and there was
translating it to English and she was
talking about all of her experiences and
when the first time a guy did it and
what what kind of diet she likes the guy
to follow when he shits in her mouth and
I'm like okay this is not pleasant I'm
not enjoying this but honestly and this
is like it's a kind of a dumb thing to
talk about right but here's why it's not
human psychology that yeah it's a person
that was a baby yes yes yes that was a
big try not to [ __ ] up all sudden this
baby's 50 and she likes guys [ __ ] in
her mouth and she wears like
Lavar for parenting should be somewhere
you know round no [ __ ] on other
people like then you know you've
succeeded by the way get a lot of money
for it like Robert when those dudes
named robert redford Indecent Proposal
do me more o million dollars and i want
to put myself out there right now yeah
just four million bucks please tweet
he's not that long I've got a new
antenna guys [ __ ] I've got a number
what's your number that's a what is your
number have to get [ __ ] on slowly every
day as a clerk at Dunkin Donuts or one
giant load on your chest that is like a
really rough afternoon
not even an afternoon it's like an hour
hit me with a giant load shower up I
think everybody says it are rounds on me
boys it just became a millionaire God
you [ __ ] on you just your impending Eric
it's like saying that it's solid what if
it was like a diary I do a lot of
whatever let him [ __ ] all of you so I
don't water as long as you have goggles
on and you you get to close your mouth
there's a lot of like things stained
windows thought experiments come up I'm
always like you wouldn't like you
wouldn't kiss a guy never told my dad
this for how much money I was like that
a million bucks
what if he goes no I got that that's
preposterous that's ridiculous you got a
problem and then he goes no I wouldn't
do it he calls back and he goes he tells
me who he names a guy in all the tallien
he's like who's a he goes Paul Sorvino
okay that's my answer
million bucks he'd make it a pulse
everybody would because the what would
you do with that money you could save
other people's lives you gotta buy a fur
coat and start balling either way it's a
million bucks yeah no matter what that's
until the money runs out now go
everywhere horrified do that
well I wouldn't either but I will make
out with Paul Sorvino
we're living in this fantasy where I why
is everything have to be ethical and
moral have a good goddamn time
white fur like Snow Leopard or some [ __ ]
something exotic what when you say that
like what do you mean why is everything
you have to be ethical or moral like you
have your moral code yeah man but I'm
talking about making out with Paul
Sorvino for a million bucks that's free
money Oh wrong oh yeah well then right
everybody should want
whoever you want if we're salsas listen
you want to make it real [ __ ] take a big
meaty meatball [ __ ] it's exactly your
magic right in your [ __ ] head yester
- three million bucks you had a bad
memory of making out with Paul Sorvino
hit on your head but the end of the day
the guy kept his promise and now you're
rich
[Applause]